[Music]
throughout the month of March and during
this newscast we've been sharing stories
about the remarkable women of Southern
Nevada these four ladies were
highlighted out of 90 nominees and one
of them has been chosen to participate
in next star woman of the year show in
Los Angeles this month and I am so
excited that out of all these incredible
stories that we've heard the remarkable
woman from Las Vegas is polita Simpson
polita congratulations I am so happy
that you're here today I'm so honored to
be able to tell your story to all of our
viewers out there and of course we have
something beautiful for you these
flowers may or may not be able to pick
up because I think they're pretty heavy
that's okay they'll just be my buddy
they are beautiful as are you as are you
and we're so so excited to be able to
honor you with this nominee and um and
really kind of enjoy and take it all in
oh my goodness I am so honored you
presented our organization and our story
so beautifully and I know the children
are so excited for this and this is so
beautiful I'm just honored and humbled
to be nominated with such amazing
remarkable women those other three women
congratulations to them and all the
great work that they do so they do yes
and all of you really so now you get the
opportunity to join a nationwide event
recognizing women from cities across the
country so polita Simpson we just we
want to celebrate everything that you
have done for the children here in this
community of course being the owner of
positively arts and it's really just a
time to kind of devote our time and
energy to everything that you have done
because you have done so much for these
kids thank you so much and I know one
thing I was extra excited about to get
this award and nomination is I got to
bring light to the children and their
stories and what they go through and the
empowerment that happens at positively
Arts so thank you again well and that's
exactly what polita does so let's go
ahead and bring in klas general manager
Jay Howell he has a very special gift
for you
congratulations polita I'm being named
our remarkable women of 2023 for Las
Vegas we know you spent a lot of time
helping kids hit the right notes as well
as teaching lessons on how to find
Harmony within themselves you and your
non-profit positively Arts also ensure
any child can take part in your classes
which will help future students on
behalf of eight news now klas and next
star Media Group we are presenting you
with a check for one thousand dollars
thank you for the amazing work you are
doing for our kids and the community
have a wonderful time in Los Angeles
with the nation's most remarkable women
Heather I'll send it back to you as I
understand we have some special messages
from some other remarkable women we
certainly do Jay thank you so much
polita there are a slew of supporters
here that love this program that we do
so let's start off with Las Vegas mayor
Carolyn Goodman oh my goodness
Hive leader and congratulations on being
Las Vegas's remarkable woman we're so
grateful to you and proud of your work
with our young people in the Arts
especially so good luck to you and have
a great great celebration
from the mayor to some of our very
special friends at CBS News as well as
the talk polita take a listen
hey hey polita Gail King here just
wanted to say congratulations to you why
you already know this you were selected
as Las Vegas remarkable woman wow wow
wow and from a group of some amazing
finalists that just shows how badass you
are the people that know you tell me
this about you that you're a true role
model that you're an important mentor to
the youth and that you're a champion for
mental health you know there's a lot of
people walking around the planet that
need help these days and you are helping
them I'm thinking we need more people
like you someone told me that meeting
you can be a life-changing experience so
I just want to say once again keep up
the great work and allow me to send my
congratulations polita give yourself a
round of applause get it
bravo bravo
hi polita as a dad I can only imagine
the grace and understanding you've given
so many kids and their parents you are
indeed a remarkable woman
there were so many diamonds selected as
finalists but your sparkle caught
everyone's eye I hope your work helping
children through positively Arts
continues to help kids feel accepted and
loved for many many years to come
congratulations polita for me and from
all of us at CBS News Sunday morning
people like you brighten every day
Hello friends and hi pelita I just
wanted to send my heartfelt
congratulations on being chosen as this
year's remarkable woman in Las Vegas and
for your nomination for next star's
Woman of the Year award thank you for
all of the remarkable work that you do
to improve the lives of so many of the
youth in Las Vegas we've been reporting
on mental health issues as well here on
the CBS Evening News and your positively
arts program is exactly what children
need so a heartfelt congratulations
hi polita I just love your story and
what you're doing for the Youth in Las
Vegas you are a remarkable woman there
are so many diamonds selected as
finalists but you are the one that
shines the brightest as a mother of two
teenage boys let me say thank you for
your work helping children who struggle
with mental health you are making such a
huge difference I hope positively Arts
continues to help our children feel
accepted and loved for many years to
come congratulations polita from me and
from all of us here at the talk
we're all losing it the mic Pack's
losing it too feels pretty good doesn't
it I am floored and I am impressed and I
am I am so honored I'm so thankful that
you and your team that mental health and
mental Wellness is Paramount for you as
well so what made me feel so touched is
feeling like there's a team behind us we
have the support because it is so needed
for our youth so as you said super
touched it takes a village and I have to
ask you for people you know who haven't
seen your story of course I implore you
to go to the website and and watch her
entire piece and go visit positively
Arts but what is your hope for the
future what is your hope for positively
Arts As you move forward yes I mean My
Hope for positively Arts is that we just
continue to be a safe haven for our
youth and that we're known for mental
wellness and being an education
organization that uses the
transformational power of the Arts as a
vehicle to build back confidence and the
resilience and to truly Empower our kids
to just be the best version of
themselves and to make sure that we
continue to give them the tools and the
coping mechanisms so they can handle
their stress and their anxiety and most
importantly that we continue to give
children the space and the time to feel
and emote so that they can figure out
who they are what is their unique and
individual voice
and then celebrate that voice with them
finding their voice and finding their
strength as as you have found through
your trials and tribulations polita
congratulations I'm honored like I said
to tell your story we're so thrilled for
you your family and friends and
supporters they're all here they're
celebrating with you I see husband there
and and mom as well and we're just so
proud to be able to Showcase what you've
been able to do and in such a short
period of time so again congratulations
and we did have the opportunity to
feature three other remarkable women so
we've got those like I said they're all
posted on our website as well as
polita's story so go to 8newsnow.com and
we'll be right back more news and
weather after
[Music]